I have the Hennessy symbol with like the
armor and yeah I have this tattoo right
here because everybody knew I was like
handy at hoes man like they know me for
dreaming stupid when I made but it was
me at the time that era where I grew up
in it was like snap backs and tattoos
like that was the that was the era of
grow up and so it was definitely
motivated me to want to be tatted I
don't see no Wiz Khalifa but the 50 was
like winning her first he had like the
crazy 50 back tattoo like that was like
one of the first people I saying that
was like stupid tatak he was tatted on
little Wayne little Wayne was a big
inspiration too and a lot of people try
to act like they don't realize that
Soulja Boy's and he came on the scene he
was getting tatted you know what I mean
he was known for getting happiness
leaves and stuff like that too so he
definitely inspired me in a way to get
tatted when I was around 18 or up you
can just these were ready and outside of
the just those who wears a piece of my
brother I was actually with my cousin at
the time when I first got it I was
scared though I know it was the first
time getting to Ted always go test was
like the worst probably the worst
feeling in the world until I got it and
when I got it I don't know if he's I
didn't sort of paint because I like the
paint because I knew what I was getting
it for or was it just not really that
bad you know I mean so even like to this
day this is what I'm like flooded is
because every time I get a tat now I
think I remind myself for the first time
I got it is like I knew we had such a
meaning to it so I didn't really think
about the pain I'm also thought about
the reason I'm getting see now and then
it became an addiction so it was like
after the first hold it was like okay I
mean this don't hurt say less ten I went
crazy
so the initial plan was a half sleeve
right so that's what I was starting on
for so I think I did this little cloud
that's around it just to try to make it
look a little full
then after the cloud I slowly went to
this little Ranger right here with the
tombstone and said September 26 2009 and
that's when my brother passed away and
then I got these birds now right now
with this arm
I'm gonna cover up so I was like in the
process so I look a little weird right
now because we I've never got a chance
to finish it but I'm basically enhancing
the birds to be bigger because at first
you can't really tell but it was like
three little birds right here and that's
all I had three little birds going up I
had all right peaking up with a little
cloud around it and there's a Z with the
tombstone that was pretty much it I got
this one next my brother's keeper so as
you can see honestly it's like a whole
tribute to my brother this whole arm is
dedicated to him and here it says
loyalty and then at the top I've got
this is like half Jesus face and his
clouds like he's looking over the clouds
I was young I was getting I was just
like going at it like it was just like
hey you got that this one being worse
you know everybody thinks the neck hurt
the neck doesn't hurt oh I don't know
why I can tolerate it but my neck ties
don't hurt at all
when I initially started it we just
outlined basically everything then we
weighed it the next day and we went back
at it again the next day so you know
about the next day the tattoo is more
swinging more sore and I didn't have the
understanding of letting the tattoo
he'll first then go back over the shape
I wanted it done so fast man worst
decision I ever made he came back tried
to shade I mean I got through it but it
was the worst feeling in the world but
it was like painting on top of paint on
top of paint I just like this area
overall is just painful then right here
this is actually a block and Brooklyn is
on Utica and Carroll Street that's where
my brother was
grew up at and it's basically like a
angel right
tombstone this world I said VIP but at
peace this is a king chest piece it goes
next to this one which is a queen chess
piece for the King is for my brother it
says pray and this says read life that's
the team I read so the other own came
about not too far after this was like
before I even finished this on before I
even really got anything done I jump to
this arm because I just felt like hey I
got too much on this side I need to
match it and I mean and at first this
was supposed to been just one sleep I
was just going to get one sleep
dedicated to my brother I was supposed
to touch nothing over here that was my
plan I wanted to have that one sleep
with that didn't turn out to be that way
right after that I went got this
microphone got like a little ribbon
going around it half my name in it and
it says establish 1992 this is the music
on this is the arm dedicated to me
anything that represents Who I am which
is music of course that's the piano I
got ma right here and a and then this is
also a piece that I'm covering up well
not really a cover but actually
enhancing it was it was three gelatin
heads which is you know evil see no evil
speak no evil but I wanted to kind of
upgrade it I just was a kid trying to
just be tatted up so I never really took
the time so I'm definitely about there
hamsters most of my tattoos I'm not -
just like upgrade to the teeth
[Music]
Kat tat she actually did my leg time and
it's my queen piece actually kW EE and
the Queen piece this is definitely my
favorite it's a big crown right here
Ashley did that on the show like ink I
think of Chicago yeah that was my
favorite man she's so dope
she did it real fast and I just think it
came out so far like she did it were
like no effort well Queens foundation
kings queens all in one spells Queens kW
EE and as a foundation me and my mom
came up with together going off like
life experiences you know losing
somebody close whether it was a sign the
daughter brothers sister
we just kind of went to give back to the
community and relate to other people too
as well as going through the same
situations only like this one this is my
least favorite and I'm just and I'm
gonna show you because there's a lot of
people out there who do get tattoos and
is it being a mistake the whole theme
was the Statue of Liberty but it was
supposed to be like me and I set out
holding the arm where's the thing like a
pitch for pitch flaming replays that
would have Mike the braze is like
hanging like my breeze is hanging from
the Liberty lady or whatever and she has
a crown off
I got stomach tats - I forgot so this
one is a girl holding a gun and smoking
a blunt that's like one of my favorites
- like it's just some bad rather die
chick and then I got one on my upper
back area it's the Brooklyn Bridge with
the city behind it the buildings aren't
just like regular buildings is like
abandoned buildings like all the
buildings in the city of New York was
like messed up so that's like the fame
is like basically showing like the
fairness of Brooklyn and it's the
Brooklyn Bridge that's like that's
actually like my second favorite one I
could say I got my chest at it
everything right here all over here it
says gods give a lot of people think it
says gods a girl and this tattoo is
really important because it's actually
on the front of my album cover like this
is just this part of my of my face and
on the uncover that God is like
basically bleeding I know it probably
looks like God's girl that's probably
the tattoo artists foot and that's
pretty much what all my tattoos is like
anything I have in me just symbolize me
like this is Aries on my Aries I'm a
double arrows matter of fact a lot of
people that don't know I'm an Aries sign
sunshine and I'm Aries movies well I
even had this on King of Hearts I
actually got this for xmi she covered
hers
I told her I didn't understand why she
got the Queen one with a heart and I
said why did you cover is not like
anybody's gonna know you know I mean she
I guess was like no
yeah I mean I kept mine because - could
stand for anything Kingdom Hearts it
stand for my first name Queen this one
the broken heart is on this side which
is you know still that in dedication to
my Brotherhood this was like the most
scariest tattoo I got because I was on
my face and I literally was like
hesitant on getting it because I didn't
know what people was gonna think it
wasn't like I didn't think he was gonna
rock with me no more I knew my mom was
gonna be like are you kidding me like
why did you do that
even my homegirl my style is like one of
my best friends it was like the first
person I actually told and she was like
you bet not getting up never gonna talk
to you again like don't touch your face
I don't have my exes tell me that at the
time and one day I just was like I don't
understand like I feel like it just it
completes like my tattoo journey like I
feel like I need this one broken heart
of my face I always wanted it to I've
been wanting a broken heart tattoo on my
face for like years now yeah this is
probably one of my most important sets
this small is what it means so much to
me I'm not personally against tattoo
like there's a lot of people who have
something against tattooing when they
feel like this it makes you look
gangster or whatever the case and me
honestly I don't get touched to look
gangster I got tests because I just feel
like it was art to me alright like I
really appreciate art and it's just
something that symbolized my life is
like a journey in life and there's like
I put it on my skin to for other people
to see I only got a Lexington gangster
[Music]